have you have you ever been Amsterdam
yeah I feel like you've given some weird
[ __ ] in Amsterdam we were to a set shot
took my girlfriend over there and we
went and watched this sex show and it
was the main stars were out I guess it
was like a flu going around and said
they had some real third stringers on
the wheel I can waterboy and is this
female cousin in there you know I mean
this is something your country probably
ate these people jinyoung but here's
what I'm saying is that it was like a
lazy susan right and so you get in these
little we get in a little room that are
all around this lazy susan and your
little room has a window that face
what's a lazy susan a lazy susan is like
a thing that spins around around mother
had like if you open her drawer okay you
know yeah in it yeah
so there's windows all around this lazy
susan yeah there's windows all around
this lazy susan and you go in and you
get your little booth and you can go
stand in there and watch it through your
window to see the lady's disease so you
can see a few other people kind of
vaguely who are in there wind I can't
see him doing like jacking off and you
can't see him but you can guess that
they're probably jacking off okay and
then you can see it a little bit in your
head you know an imagination yeah then
what was going on on the show I was in
there oh it's too [ __ ] I mean it was
like the guy could barely even [ __ ] it
was like he had just won like a [ __ ]
drawing somewhere that he'd never
thought he would win you know but he did
all the entries and it was like it was
[ __ ] somebody like have any knew he
wasn't supposed to be [ __ ] you know
it's like the first couple times like
you ever peer here yourself but you
don't put it all the way through the
first time you just kind of keep
checking for where it's okay that cos is
- bro it was like you just try to figure
it out on the fly working the freelance
working freelance man was in the girl
who's not hot the girl was not
Brown and then here's the crazy thing
denna didn't want to watch them [ __ ] no
I wouldn't do you have to stay in your
little cage until the daily finishes
[Laughter]
those were the rules so you just have to
stay in there until like its until like
there's a certain amount of time I think
it's three minutes and you get in there
before your door open oh thank you so
then you're like locked in and watching
these people [ __ ] dude and it's almost
it got harrowing man I was like I was
like cheering at first for kind of for
somebody and then I wasn't and then I
just like it's like when you don't wanna
watch the game anymore
yeah you're over it again turn the [ __ ]
off then was your girl feeling it I
think she was due but she and I had a
tough go out there in Europe my eyes
just like traveling around and I would
never a lot of money so we're doing it
there's a while ago yeah this probably
bout nine years ago
okay and we're you know we're traveling
around you know back pack in a state
like Pam out at campgrounds and [ __ ]
like that you know it's [ __ ] cheap
dude you know and so we're staying out
of campgrounds a shot like morning mist
and like other tourists were saying we
were staying like we're local poor
people were close we got the real but
she probably hated it I was Rocky man it
was rock you guys are you all the time
out there oh we almost got arrested at
this grocery store they she was beating
me with [ __ ] frozen items with
semi-frozen little first Precinct as
deep as we do yeah waste a lot of
electricity freeze and stuff real deep
over here we freeze to deep I agree with
that I've always thought that man you go
in there some of that shake it's too
much we don't need this song her keys
you're like what the [ __ ] frozen solid
like what they did days dawg yeah they
do yeah I want to read the backstory on
this thing to see if he deserved this
because they'll have this birds it's
unbelievable yeah man
so that you and that girl did when you
got back did you break up with her yeah
I remember oh I remember the last moment
really of our relationship was she I was
at the bottom of one of those um you
know moving staircases escalators and
she pushed the [ __ ] luggage we had
where one of the smart carts yeah
and I was yelling something from the
bottom and she just pushed that
[ __ ] right down the escalator
spicy spicy yeah white girl yeah yeah
pretty white man and the UH and that was
it man when he got back though you find
out a lot about someone on a long trip
yeah and I met her I was the problem I
maybe I'm sure it's both maybe just
didn't mix fried get to good people just
didn't mix especially it's stressful no
money you travel around Europe even
watch this this mutant [ __ ] this other
thing you know like I didn't help the
cause wasn't a fine it was bad Rosina of
the it was like Rams and the Giants
played a bomba it's a waste of time
Jesus Christ it's not even raining and
they're playing like it's in the rain
people have yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]